a big part of the job is looking for the
worst to people
turns out I excel at that your pie I'm
just trying to make a living you know
boost costs money usually
Jessica Jones I saw you what do you want
now can you touch the wall
stop moving call a slow moving car
way I see it being a hero just put a
target on your back
I've been there done that this doll what
if there was someone else out there but
his ability was to make people do
whatever he wanted he liked my control
you have no idea what I've done what he
made me do Jess isn't here now he's
always here
yes you'd like to invite me in in watch
absolutely
killgrave leaves a trail of broken
people behind him you made me jump for
hours as high as I could he said I was
never as good as you
he's back he's coming for me
let's start now
Jessica I'm the only one who matches you
where inevitable
Oh God didn't do this the devil did
I'm fine
mr. ha Jessica I am this stone I play
the hair out of me
I am the storm Zoey
you